có khoảng 9,5% của bỗ th же tạm tái pu 就u có chạm thu法.
Giữa mạnh mề 2,5%, một khối lợn đất đặt sà s root bắt đường,
giới ág tác cả 2 chầu.
Tên này đất đ ra tiếp tục của giấu hiệu di chuyển
tìm an vehicle Mất Arn góan,
lưu lượng cảnh sà sau thông đường bộ xổ mô tỉnh lâu cai các cửi lực lượng quan vùng
viêm, đặt biển cạnh báo và tạm thời hàng trên phương tiệm
qua pu cực trạm thu法, vô têtes, nhằm bảo đảm án góan.
Phương tiệm câu giới được quy động để khắp,
Cơ qua trước năng khuyền càng người dân và các phương tiện khi liều thông qua khu vực cũng lộ bún đây,
đặc biệt loạn qua khu vực sát, tả phía, cần hết sức, cần trọng, tôn thủ, hướng, dẫn, điều tiết sau thông và hạn chế dừng đổ,
tả khu vực có nghĩa có sả lợ.